The court considers that
with regard to the present situation,
Israel must,
in accordance with its obligations under the Genocide
Convention in relation to Palestinians in Gaza,
take all measures within its power
to prevent the commission of all acts
within the scope of article 2 of the convention,
in particular
a killing groups
members of the group,
b causing serious
bodily or mental harm to members of the group
C deliberately inflicting on the group
conditions of life calculated to bring about
its physical destruction in the holaryn part
and d imposing measures
intended to prevent bursts within the group.